Speaker 1: A Republican focus group
very clearly turned on Donald Trump.
This is fascinating stuff. Many of you know,
pollster and focus group leader Frank Luntz,
who has been working on and testing messaging
and language and ideas for the Republican Party
for a very long time. And recently, this is
about ten days old at this point in time.
He did a focus group with Republican voters taking
their temperature now beyond the midterm midterm
elections about Trump and about Trump versus
DeSantis, this focus group and of course, with
any such focus focus group, there's a question
of how representative is the focus group, really?
It's anecdotes you're not going to get with just
a couple dozen or a dozen people. You're not going
to get a fully representative sample of some of
a group as large as the Republican voting base.
But it's interesting anecdotally, nonetheless,
take a listen to what some of these folks say.
Speaker 2: First, one word or phrase that
you use to describe Donald Trump right now,
stay off Twitter. The gentleman from Iowa.
Speaker 3: I was just going to say the same thing.
You know, his new one that he's
on. I think he needs to take a
break from that one.
Speaker 2: Becky.
Speaker 3: Narcissist.
Speaker 2: Lisa.
Speaker 3: Keep doing what you're doing.
Speaker 2: Andrew. Tired John. Unsteadily melody.
Speaker 3: High hopes.
Speaker 2: Great mistakes.
John from North Dakota Unrelenting.
Speaker 3: Cathy Stowe. Right.
Speaker 2: Eric. Advice.
Jim. Over. John from Georgia.
Fighter. David from California, racist jab from
Texas. Sanctimonious. Oh, is he from Indiana?
Speaker 3: Is this man.
Speaker 2: Nancy from Illinois? I calculated
I would do the same thing now with the
governor of Florida, Ron DeSantis. I'm
going to go in the exact opposite order.
Right. Promising states here. Indiana.
Speaker 3: Oh, geez. Interesting.
Speaker 2: Jeb from Texas, bad ass.
Kathy from Pennsylvania.
Speaker 3: A leader.
Speaker 2: Eric from North Carolina, very
powerful. Jim from Indiana rising. John
David from Georgia. Same thing, Biter. David from
California. Promising. Andrew from South Carolina.
Leader John from California.
Visionary. Melody from Washington.
Speaker 3: Amazing.
Speaker 2: From New York.
Speaker 3: The future.
Speaker 2: John from North
Dakota. Our apologies. Lisa from New
York. Gutsy. Thank you. From Virginia.
Speaker 3: Future of the party.
Speaker 2: Jamie from Iowa.
Speaker 3: Refreshing. Later.
Speaker 2: Gregory from Nevada.
Future of the party so far.
Speaker 1: So that is pretty interesting. Now,
of course, it's completely anecdotal, but that
sentiment increasingly tired of Trump. Sick of
the antics. Sick of the posts and the like
mirrored by what we are seeing in the polls,
increasingly pointing more towards the idea of
Ron DeSantis as the future of the party. Now,
as I've said before, I don't know that this
is any big party to write home about, because
if DeSantis were to become the next President of
the United States, there is no doubt in the world
that he would be about as dangerous as
Trump in terms of ideas, but far more
dangerous in terms of his ability to
execute because he's less incompetent.
That's the risk. And so when we think about the
2024 Republican primary, not that we vote in it,
by and large, the question of who do we prefer win
the primary has to be contextualized in who are we
worse off if they actually become president of
the United States and in a way, an 80 year old
incompetent Trump to me seems less acutely
dangerous than Ron DeSantis. And I'm willing
to have my mind changed and my feelings may evolve
over the course of the primary. Remember a primary
in which Ron DeSantis has not even yet said he's
participating? But I want to hear from you. Leave
a comment. Send an email info at David Pakman
dot com. Send a tweet however you want to get
in touch, smoke, signals, telegrams, etc.. Let me
know what you think about this. Who would actually
be more dangerous if they became president?
I want to hear from you. We will look at some
comments on an upcoming episode of the show. Quick
break and then we will come back. We're going to
talk about 17 guilty verdicts against the Trump
Organization. That's a big story and so much more